foreign
what's up Taylor
hi Dr John how are you good what are you
doing
oh you know partying
excellent It's like 10 in the morning
I'm I'm excellent we should probably
talk about that yeah that may be another
call but we can talk about that
what are you up to you having fun
um so my siblings and I are kind of at a
Crossroads we are trying to figure out
how to maintain a
relationship with our parents they have
a hoarding issue and now it's becoming a
health concern and we're wondering how
we can help them stay well while still
respecting their things and respecting
their space
oh that's hard and I know you know that
tell me before I jump into that tell me
some of the challenges y'all
tell me some of the things you've tried
to do let me ask that way
an issue that they've both had
throughout our entire lives
um but it's recently come to light that
my dad has congestive heart failure and
she's going in for a triple bypass so
it's become more of a a priority to give
him a clean healing space to recover
that's safe for him to move around
without worrying about tripping or
slipping
and the challenge with
um hoarding is that safety comes from
that environment the perceived the
perception of safety right
and so in order to make somebody like
truly safe you've got to make their feel
very unsafe
um how's your mom responded to this not
well I'm assuming
not well
about a week ago and we started cleaning
out uh one of the bedrooms
three of us about six hours and that
probably didn't go well did it
how'd you know what because I've I've
sat with hoarders before it's very
challenging
um I've helped I've helped people get
stuff out of their homes before it's
very very challenging
um yeah that's tough tough tough tell me
about it
um well
[Music]
random pieces of furniture random
clothing tons and tons of hygiene
products
um my brother came down with a covered
trailer it was a seven by ten and we
completely filled it out of one bedroom
um Dad was pretty on board with it uh
there were a couple of things that they
both asked us to keep so we tried to be
as respectful as possible and set those
things off to the side
um Dad was pretty on board with getting
things cleaned up there were a couple of
things that you could tell were harder
for him to let go of but Mom seemed to
struggle with it more so we were trying
to push the
idea that this is this isn't about your
things we're not just trying to you know
come over and wipe you out and take all
of your stuff but this is about Dad's
health right now and that's obviously
much bigger than any tangible thing you
can hold in this world right and
it seemed to sink in a little bit and
then an hour later we would be right
back to square a that's right that's
right I my guess would be just based off
that one little snippet um has your
mother been the driver
foreign has she been the one over time
accumulating things dealing with anxiety
dealing with this internal stress by
just accumulating and accumulating and
your dad just kind of lived in it
um and then it became part of their
world
the anxious quarter like you had said
and I feel like Dad is more of a
gracious quarter where if he buys things
of the intention of giving them to
people and then they get lost in the mix
and they just sit there right both of
those are better intentions both so go
ahead as you work through this
you have um are looking at this very
logically okay and fear and panic and
anxiety those are very illogical systems
they don't your brain doesn't want you
logically wondering how kind or nice
that tiger is at the front of the door
it just wants you to get out of there
right so it screams at you it sounds all
your alarms and you get out of town
right then you come to find out that
that tiger is actually your neighbor's
tiger and it's super sweet has no claws
no teeth and it's just lovely right who
cares your brain said tell you I'm out
of here right so you've heard of fight
flight or freeze as trauma responses as
the things that your body does to get
you out of a situation stress response
there's also a fourth one called Fawn
where you nuzzle up you
um maybe if I am extra loving extra
close
that will help ease this anxiety I feel
in this relationship
and so your mother may have one impulse
that is I'm going to accumulate in case
for out of scarcity
um I saw that they were in a toilet
paper they may run out of sun I mean
soap and deodorant and all these things
right and then all of a sudden the
Train's out of the station and your dad
may be doing something similar where his
anxiety is I'm going to try to bridge
the gap between relationships and
instead of sitting down in a rocking
chair and just saying I love you tell me
about your day I'm going to buy stuff
I'm going to buy stuff I'm gonna buy
stuff he never actually gets around
giving it away but it's always this idea
that this is some altruistic motive it's
not really really they're both the same
impulse and as covering up a brain that
is screaming for that we're not safe
we're not safe we're not safe and that's
what makes cleaning up so hard is your
logical brain the part of your head that
says this could all tip over on me and
I'm gonna die or the one that could do
the math and say I could open a new bar
of soap every day for the rest of my
life I'm only going to live 20 more
years that's this many more days I have
that much soap in my home this is this
is madness but you try to get rid of
that soap and your body turns all the
alarm systems on and it's very hard so
your mother is actually trying to Noble
thing which is I hear you I trust you
and then just an hour later her brain is
like ah it's all going like they're
they're peeling back all of our layers
of safety which makes this really hard
um
so
your situation is I don't say it's rare
but it's not one that everybody's gonna
um run into
but what something everybody is going to
run into is
we need to have some hard conversations
and some boundary conversations with our
parents about finances about safety
about their mental health about whatever
and how do we do that
um ultimately I think you are 100
correct your dad cannot go back to a
home that is
um
unsafe and it's unsafe both structurally
but it's also unsafe the rats and mice
that will live in that stuff and they
haven't found any evidence of their
presence yes exactly I mean so you pile
that much stuff anywhere and rats and
mice are going to live in there and he
can't breathe that
um the infection risk all of that so the
question you and your siblings need to
ask is this
um
yeah
how far are we willing to go
and to keep Dad safe versus let him ride
out his last days how he wants to
what I mean is there may come a moment
when you have to call notify the social
worker at the hospital that's going to
talk to him about his release and you
need to let that person know that his
current home is unsafe and either he has
to go to a home or your mother has to
allow a team to come in there and clean
that thing top to bottom and that
usually involves one or two of those big
dumpsters get dropped off in the front
yard and a team will go in there and
just take everything and get the carpets
redone or clean or new carpet paint the
walls like the house is going to need to
be
um really overhauled so that he's safe
um
short that you're talking about we're
just going to nickel and dime this thing
and that room will fill back up with
junk the because you're really you're
not getting the core issue the core
issue is not the stuff
the core issue is your mom and dad
aren't well and now they're getting to
an age where their Wellness is kind of
rolling back on you right
correct so how far are y'all willing to
go
um I mean we're pretty deep into it mom
has been pretty good about letting a
couple of my siblings come over because
they live pretty far away from all of us
so we're all just trying to tag teams as
far as when we can make it up there to
do some cleaning here there in between
our own lives and schedules and work and
families and things like that
um
but as far as like I guess we don't
really know what all the options are
like we've kind of taken this on as we
have to figure this out and we have a
very short amount amount of time to do
this
um my two sisters are coming up from
Texas for his surgery
um which was recently put off for
another couple of weeks which is almost
a godsend if he is stable enough to like
for that couple weeks
um for us to have more time to to handle
this and figure this out because yeah
we're kind of all in a mad Dodge will
anybody
um would anybody take him in for a month
I don't know if any of us could to be
honest like I live two hours away in a
one bedroom apartment the bathroom is on
a separate level than the rest of the
living yeah so I don't know if that
would work for him I I don't know if my
brother and his family could do it okay
ultimately here's the framework for
making the decision
you and your siblings right now y'all
are trying to nickel and dime this thing
and quite honestly it's probably not
going to work
it might you might create a single
bedroom with some space in it and that's
cool my guess is
um especially with folks who collect
hygiene Pro like the best the bathroom's
wild is that fair
it was before I cleaned it last weekend
well done very good
um thank you there were lots of clubs
involved yes if you don't deal with that
core issue it will just refill itself
and it'll have clothes in there and
ironing boards and stuff that doesn't I
mean that you wouldn't traditionally put
in a bathroom it's just going to fill up
that way the framework here is this how
far are we going to let Dad back in that
house yes or no
if the answer is yes under what
parameters
if we're not going to let them back in
there are we all in a position is he in
a position to pay for a one-bedroom
apartment he can live in while he heals
for six months just on a six month lease
will one of us take him in do we have
money to pitch in and get him a rehab
home right this is a matter of hey we're
all like willing to get dirty and
aggressive and all this
there's a much bigger issue at play here
that much much deeper reality here that
I think everybody's got to deal with the
other thing that you can't miss is this
you got a brother and a sister is that
right
um three sisters and a brother okay okay
so there's actually a chunk of folks
that's great
um the five of you are grieving this
yourselves too
because Dad's having that's scary for
anybody's Dad to have that that level of
surgery for Mom not to be well to have
to go in there and see the stuff in your
parents home these kind of things bring
up junk in all of us too and if you
don't deal with that then the exercise
of cleaning becomes the uh anesthetic
that becomes the Xanax it becomes the
thing we do to cover over the pain
instead of getting to that root cause
and dealing with it and so
I think there just needs to be a zoom
call of some sort for all your brothers
and if your brother and your sisters
everybody get on the same page and you
can lead it and
wonder what conditions do we let Dad
move back in if I say let him move in
he's a grown-up he can maybe do what he
wants to but then we're going to make a
formal Report with the social worker and
say his living environment is not safe
somebody needs to do a welfare check is
the words on his home and see if
somebody if he should be allowed to move
back in and my guess is they would say
absolutely not and then can any of us
take him for 30 days or 60 days in our
homes yes it's going to be inconvenient
but he's our dad right
does he have the money do you all have
the money to pitch in and get him a six
month lease at a small apartment well
you all continue to drive back and forth
to nickel and dimness or will your mom
sit down and have a really hard
conversation which is we're about to
pull the trigger on all this stuff or
we're going to hire a crew to come in
there and take care of your home
and maybe she's found some peace in that
bathroom she's found some peace in that
bedroom that didn't exist previously
that'd be fantastic if she did my guess
is probably not it's probably very
stressful for her to go in there but
maybe not
um
but man she did that'd be fantastic then
you could hire a crew get in there and
get that stuff cleaned out over a
weekend and everybody pitches in four or
five hundred bucks that of course none
of you'll have that but you do it anyway
and then man Now We're Off to the Races
dad can come home but I think there's a
level of reality that we got to get to
and you're not the only one almost all
of us have to get to that level of
reality with our parents and say this is
actually what we're dealing with and
then what decisions are we going to make
moving forward but thank you so much for
that call let me know how those talks go
I really want to follow up on this one
let me know those talks go let me know
um if your mom ultimately comes around
and let me know how the surgery goes and
we'll be thinking about your dad